Uber is one of the companies disrupting the world.
This March, the ride-sharing service celebrates its 7th anniversary.
Uber has more than 160,000 drivers in nearly 400 cities.
The company is valued at upwards of 60 billion dollars.
Cofounder Travis Kalanick is now focused on the road ahead.
Kalanick told Charlie Rose of CBS News,...
"We look at all of the cities around the world..."
"...and we know that the transportation systems are not serving everybody's need."
He continued, "Most successful entrepreneurs are not waiting for success..."
"...and not waiting for progress."
We're generally a little bit forward leaning when it comes to trying to make progress happen.